MARTIN GORNER: Hello
and welcome back
to root access Berlin.
We are recording again from the
new studio at the factory,
and today I have with me
Mustafa Sezgin from
SoundCloud.
Hello Mustafa.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Hi.
MARTIN GORNER: Can you
introduce yourself?
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Sure.
So I'm the director of mobile
engineering at SoundCloud, and
I lead up basically the native
mobile applications and the
development of those at
SoundCloud at the moment.
MARTIN GORNER: And so you wanted
to tell us about a
design pattern that you have
recently started using at
SoundCloud.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Yeah.
So one of the common problems
that we have on native mobile
applications is having to
obviously have a responsive
user interface, and to do that,
you generally need to
jump off the main UI thread to
retrieve some work where the
information comes from some IO
source, whether that's from
the network or from the data.
There are a lot of components
build in to some of these SDKs
that help with that, but one of
the recent frameworks that
we've started to use is RxJava,
which was developed by
the Netflix guys who have come
together and put together
really good library.
And we've started to use that
to kind of replace a lot of
the work that we do when
retrieving information,
whether it be from the database
or from our back end
APIs at the moment.
MARTIN GORNER: And so you wanted
to show us a demo--
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Yep.
MARTIN GORNER: --of one of the
flows that you have refactored
using this reactive
programming--
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Yes.
MARTIN GORNER: --in your
Android application.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: That's
correct, yeah.
MARTIN GORNER: So let's
see the demo.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Sure.
There's a number of areas
where we've done that
refactoring, but I'll show
you one of the screens
where we've done this.
So, for a user who basically
wants to sign up, they come
in, we've already got a Google
account on here.
So we'll sign in with Google,
we accept that.
That logs us in.
And we'll see here, this is our
onboard in process where
we're able to actually see
a number of different
categories.
For someone who's just signed
up, they can basically find
some of their favorite
artists, maybe.
So if they like rock, they can
go in here and they can see
all the different artists.
MARTIN GORNER: And so this data
is something you pull
from your server?
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: That's
correct.
MARTIN GORNER: The list of
genres and the list of the top
artists in these genres.
What we want to do here is on
the device call a network API,
so something that returns data
from the SoundCloud APIs.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Yep.
MARTIN GORNER: And process those
data, get them back on
the menu [INAUDIBLE]
and display them.
So if I wanted to do this by
hand, because this is a very,
very common problem, doing
things asynchronously.
If I wanted to do this by
hand using threads and
synchronizing the results,
what would be
the amount of work?
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: There is, if you
really want to go to very
low level and kind of schedule
your own threads and worry
about synchronization,
inconcurrency is a very
difficult problem to solve when
you're developing software.
There are frameworks that are
available, or components that
are available in the Android
SDK, such as AsyncTasks, that
handle this.
But they are quite basic
in what they provide.
They do take care of the low
level threading concerns, but
when it comes to error
handling, or applying
transformations on the data
set, or even, I guess,
scheduling, at times as well, it
provides either no or very
little functionality with
regards to that.
So there's a lot of extra
functionality and useful
functionality built into RxJava
that, I guess, makes it
more attractive than using some
of the built in Android
SDK components.
MARTIN GORNER: So let's
see how it works.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Sure,
absolutely.
MARTIN GORNER: Here we have
the first little bit of
psedo-code to understand
what will be going on.
This helped me personally
understand--
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Yep.
MARTIN GORNER: --because once we
go to the Java code, there
is a little bit of extra
syntactic sugar to make this
work in Java.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Yep.
MARTIN GORNER: But the basics
are actually quite simple.
Can you tell us what
is going on?
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Sure.
So, you could consider that
using kind of the publish
subscribe panel, the observable
pattern, you have
your data stream, which in the
land of RxJava, is your
observable.
You want to observe your
data stream, basically.
So the first thing that you need
to kind of obviously do
is have an observable
data stream.
And the person or, I guess,
the component which is
interested in this data stream
needs to subscribe to it, and
that's what we see in the
first line there.
MARTIN GORNER: So that first
line actually launches the
asynchronous processing.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Yes.
MARTIN GORNER: You subscribe the
observable to an observer,
and basically what you do is
that you register this doNext
function, which is
a callback--
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Yep.
MARTIN GORNER: --on
your observable.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: That's
correct.
So basically the work itself,
very simplistically, the
observable there contains all
the logic required to retrieve
your data asynchronously.
As soon as you call subscribe
and pass in that doNext
function, RxJava kind of takes
care of the rest to launch you
thread and then basically
execute you observable, which
is the red line that we see
there with the call function.
MARTIN GORNER: And the
call function is
something that you define.
So that's your function,
you define what
work you want to do--
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: That's
correct.
MARTIN GORNER: --then, at the
end, you will call that doNext
function, which you have
[? in past ?].
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: That's
correct.
So once RxJava calls your
observable to execute it, you
will do your work and obtain
your data, and then you'll
pass your data to the callback
function, which is that doNext
function that we have
provided there.
MARTIN GORNER: So let's
see that with a
real Java code now.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Yes.
MARTIN GORNER: So this is how
you define an observable.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: It's very--
because of the wording, a lot of
people misuse those or for
one another.
But basically, in this first
slide, what we're doing is
we're actually--
a very simplistic example is we
want to make a network call
to some back end API.
And so, what we do is we try and
be as functional as we can
be in Java, and we create
this observable object.
And we talked about that call
function, and that is where
you do your work.
MARTIN GORNER: So the client
does not make request, that is
your work, your API call.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: That's
correct, yeah.
So you're making an API request
there, and you get
back a response.
Now the next lines are where
kind of a lot of the magic
happens, in a way.
So, you can see that you passed
in the observer, which
is basically that callback
function that we were talking
about earlier.
And once you have your data, you
pass it to the observer by
calling on next.
And you can do this multiple
times if you have a collection
of objects, for example.
You can loop over those and then
basically be calling on
next multiple times
to provide that
data until it's completed.
And at the end, once you've
streamed all your data, you
have to call on complete to
signal to the caller that the
stream has ended.
MARTIN GORNER: So let us see
what an observer looks like.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Sure.
What we're doing here is now
that we've created our
observable, the interested
party wants to basically
subscribe to the data that's
going to come back from that
observable.
And you can see there that, once
again, we create a kind
of an anonymous inner class,
which is that observer to the
subscribe function.
And it has to implement those
three methods there.
The first one, which is I guess
the most important one,
is on next function, and that is
what will receive the data.
And whatever kind of processing
you want to do as a
result of that data, you
should be doing in that
function there.
And once you receive-- and, as
I mentioned, that can be
called multiple times, executed
multiple times--
and once you've completed
streaming your data, you need
to call on completed, and that
will basically signal to the
observer that the stream has
ended, and that there's no
more data to come.
Now, as I mentioned earlier as
well, there's built in error
handling into RxJava.
So if an exception gets raised
that you didn't catch during
the work function, and why you
would retrieve a network I/O
error or something, that
exception will automatically
be handled by RxJava, and will
be passed through to the on
error handler or callback
in your observer.
MARTIN GORNER: That's
very handy.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: It
is very hand.
MARTIN GORNER: And so the last
issue we have to addresses is
that RxJava is a genetic
framework.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Yep.
MARTIN GORNER: But on Android,
you want your results
delivered on a specific thread,
which is the UI thread.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: That's
correct.
MARTIN GORNER: So how
do you do that?
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: So the
observable has two methods
that basically we saw in
the previous slide.
The first one was--
MARTIN GORNER: Let's
go back to it.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Yep.
The first one there was
a subscribe on.
What that means is that that's
where you specify a scheduler
that you want the actual work
function to be completed on.
So in this instance, it was
making the API call.
But the really cool thing is
that the observe on method
there that you see on the
observable specifies a
separate scheduler where you
can actually specify which
thread the data will
be delivered on.
Now, in Android land, whenever
you want to update the user
interface on the device, you
need to be doing that work on
the main UI thread.
MARTIN GORNER: And so there
are a couple more lines of
code to define a scheduler
that will
handle the data on the--
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: UI thread.
MARTIN GORNER: --main
UI thread.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: That's
correct.
Now, this is very simplistic.
There's a scheduler class within
RxJava that you need to
subclass, and it has two
abstract schedule methods that
you'll need to implement.
This is a very simplistic
implementation of one of them,
but what we do here is basically
we specify that
there's basically a handler
which runs runables on the
main looper, which is
the main UI thread.
MARTIN GORNER: And the
main looper is the
main Android UI thread.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: That's
correct.
MARTIN GORNER: That is a call
to the Android [INAUDIBLE].
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: This is all
mainly Android code, yes, and
this will exist in, like I
said, the scheduler that
you'll subclass.
And what this does is it tells
RxJava to execute that actio,
the action.call class, or the
actual call line that we see
there in the run method, which
will deliver those results
that are passed through on next
to the observer on the
main UI thread.
MARTIN GORNER: When you are
shopping around for a library
like this, have you evaluated
other possibilities?
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: In Android, one
of the common components
is obviously async task, and
some of the other components
that live in the Android SDK.
There are some extra--
for those that are familiar with
libraries like Robojuice,
which provide some dependency
injection functionality as
well, they extend some
of the async task
functionality there as well.
We found with RxJava, in
comparison to using some of
these standard libraries or
components in the SDKs, is
that it not only takes care of
a lot of those low level
concerns, but it provides some
extra functionality to take
care of the error handling,
as well.
But on top of that, a lot of
times, you want to apply
transformations on your data.
There's a lot of built in
functionality within RxJava to
apply transformations like
filtering or actually
transforming the data
itself before being
delivered to the caller.
And on top of that, one really
interesting piece of
functionality is that you can
actually combine data from
multiple sources.
So if you need to go, for
example, to your database, and
you need to go to the API, and
then you need to compose the
data set into a single stream
of data, RxJava actually has
built in functionality to be
able to do that quite easily.
So there's a lot of extra
functionality and useful
functionality built
into RxJava.
MARTIN GORNER: I hope you will
enjoy playing with reactive
programming, and thank you
very much, Mustafa--
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Thank
you for having me.
MARTIN GORNER: --for being with
us on root access Berlin.
MUSTAFA SEZGIN: Sure.
Thank you.